non so se vi ricordate l'intervista che
ho fatto a steven spielberg qualche anno
fa quando i think about it and wine
shire
lo intervistai appunto il video lo
trovate qua sul canale per l'uscita del
suo film red i player one che d'altro
molto molto carino con recuperato però
se non l'avete visto il re di player one
diciamo che esiste questa realtà
di videogiochi sostanzialmente ma non
solo
dove tu hai un avatar all'interno di
questo mondo incredibile e puoi fare un
miliardo di cose quindi esiste un mondo
alternativo online quindi tutti metti
questo visore tipo il visore bouar e
vivi all'interno di questo di questo
modo un po tipo sword arte online per
intenderci
il film era una bomba infatti la seconda
domanda e volevo fare a spielberg era
secondo te questa cosa potrà diventare
realtà tra un po di tempo però ho
preferito fare la domanda più importante
che era lì comunque tornando al discorso
appunto chissà se un giorno succederà
questa cosa bene è la zuckerberg il
nostro marcolino decide di
appunto il metaverso che avete avrete
sicuramente sentito in questi in questi
ultimi mesi giorni insomma che cos'è il
metaverso secondo marcolino non è altro
che un mondo alternativo
ovviamente digitale dove voi potete
immergervi all'interno e potete essere
più vicini a tutte le persone che lo
utilizzano appunto per allenarmi insieme
ci sono gli sport per guardare un film
nella stessa stanza però tutti quanti in
realtà siamo in stanze diverse
per giocare per un sacco di cose insomma
è veramente da come ce la stanno
raccontando veramente ready player one
dove la moneta all'interno appunto
utilizzata sono gli nfp le cripto
insomma tutto questo però non parliamo
di queste sono diventa un video
lunghissimo
a parte che non so non me ne intendo
neanche troppo quindi non avrebbe molto
senso comunque si sta pensando a questa
cosa qua ora questo non video
informativo come vi ripeto sempre perché
io porto opinioni personali più che
altro sul sul canale voleva realizzare
con voi un paio di cose la prima è la
domanda che tutti si fanno è ma questo
metaverso andrà a rovinare il futuro a
migliorare il futuro e ci sono un sacco
di pareri su internet ragazzi un casino
pareri contrapposti in una maniera
incredibile a si sta roba ne abbiamo
bisogno e altri che dicono no che merda
non viviamo più è finita e fini ciao io
personalmente ragazzi non so bene da che
parte stare perché ci sono secondo me
ancora troppe poche informazioni per
poter giudicare questa cosa nel senso
che se ci pensate questo un progetto
ambiziosissimo nel senso che per
realizzarlo ci vogliono veramente
anni anni anni di lavoro intensivo ma
poi comunque ragazzi ci stiamo parlando
di una roba
titanica quindi io non so veramente
quanto in realtà
riusciranno a realizzare quello di cui
stanno parlando cioè loro lo fanno
vedere un po come se fosse la
rivoluzione del mondo però vi faccio un
esempio ai tempi avevano lanciato l'idea
di pokemon go prima ancora che uscisse
aveva lasciato questo trailer
spiegando cosa fosse pokemon gol con
questo video qua
quando poi la realtà dei fatti
totalmente diversa da quello che abbiamo
visto quindi è normale che per creare
hype su un progetto ci venga presentato
nella maniera più ambiziosa possibile
però
quando mi parlano del fatto che ha sia
all'interno del metaverso tu potrai
rivivere ad esempio le civiltà antiche
potrebbe essere l'antica roma e vedere
girare in giro si ok ma chi è che la
pasta cosa vogliamo basso ceco le
aspettative non facciamoci aspetta di
incredibili perché poi rovinano un po
la fruizione del contenuto vedi un po un
gioco abbastanza futuristico uscito da
non troppo tempo che non ha totalmente
avuto il risultato sperato però l'aper a
mille quindi fly down parliamo appunto
anche del fatto che per farvi un esempio
io quando hanno lanciato locus rift che
è stato uno dei primi progetti forse il
primo vero progetto così grande per
quanto riguarda il wu'er io comprai
subito il progetto per farci video sopra
ovviamente perché a livello di contenuto
portavano un sacco perché ce l'avevamo
in due il guar lo comprai così subito
non so se vi ricordate vi dai tempi è
effettivamente era molto carina come
come idea però non era così tanto
immersiva come ci si aspettava perché vi
faccio un esempio il guar che cos'è
questo schermo che voi vi mettete in
faccia ok e se muovete la testa nel
gioco si muove la testa fine ok questo è
poi hanno implementato anche i muri
europea però vabbè lasciamo perdere
quello parliamo solo del sensore ma non
è altro che uno schermo attaccate ai
vostri occhi
con il sensore bust fine è questo il vr
in realtà adesso te l'ho fatta molto
semplice sì ma non è che sia incredibile
ok ora ragazzi mettiamo un attimo da
parte il chissà come verrà fuori se
verrà fuori veramente comincia lo stanno
presentando o se sarà un po una sorta di
surrogato del surrogato di cui del video
che dei video dimostrativi che ci sono
stati mostrati facciamo finta che verrà
fuori esattamente come ce lo mostrano ok
quindi fruibile da tutti
facile da utilizzare immediato e
soprattutto utile perché col collo
appunto il metaverso voi potreste essere
nella con persone dall'altra parte del
mondo e quindi godere di una serata
tutti insieme come se vedesse proprio
dal vivo
ecco
queste cose un po spaventosa c'è un po
tanto e l'altra spaventosa perché se ci
pensate qua si parla quasi di
riscrivere totalmente la vita di una
persona da cui a tot anni ok perché se
veramente ci si incontrerà così
severamente le giornate le passeremo
così
tanto incisivo sulla vita delle persone
questo perché se voi pensate che
attualmente zuckerberg con i suoi
social le sue piattaforme insomma
whatsapp instagram pe2 possiede il
controllo su come comunicano tra di loro
all'incirca tre miliardi di persone
che non sono proprio
pochissime ok e sembrano comunque di
servizi di messaggistica oppure dei
social quindi niente a che vedere con un
metaverso quindi una roba dove tutti
immergi però se ci pensate quanto tempo
stiamo al telefono solo perché per gesto
prendiamo il telefono e controlliamo le
notifiche o qualcosa del genere ecco se
questa cosa si è già discusso tantissimo
però fateci caso immaginatevi se entra
proprio a far parte delle nostre
giornate nel senso che per fare una
determinata azione tu devi per forza
passare attraverso il metaverso ok
quindi c'è tanto da discutere su questo
poi ovviamente dipende da come decidano
di svilupparlo e come verrà fuori però
dei dibattiti si sono già creati anzi
web attualmente piena visti dibattiti io
come ho già detto non mi sento di
prendere nessuna delle due parti perché
mi sento di avere troppe poche
informazioni per farlo però comunque
diamoci una pensata perché è una cosa un
po un po un po strambi detto questo
comunque c'è chi dice vabbè ma non è che
ti obbligano a usarlo nel senso che non
è che da quando cioè metaverso tu devi
usare perché sono ok però se ci pensate
questa cosa molto importante
da quando esistono cosap
eastern insomma tutti i servizi che
utilizziamo praticamente tutti quanti
non è che voi siete obbligati e
riutilizza nessuno vi sta dicendo no usa
whatsapp muoviti perché sennò sono cazzi
tuoi no
però dal momento in cui tutti lo
utilizzano e tu decidi di non
utilizzarlo automaticamente di tempo
tagliando fuori dalla società
e questa cosa a me in realtà è successa
perché io non so se ve l'avevo detto mi
pare di sì nelle interviste con quel
avevo raccontato sta cosa più o meno a
marzo del 2021 ha deciso di togliermi da
i social ottimi sono tuttora facebook
instagram e whatsapp ovviamente non è
che ho cancellato gli account
semplicemente tolto le applicazioni dal
mio telefono ok quindi iniziato a
utilizzare il telefono solo per
questioni di necessità tutte le persone
che volevano scrivermi o comunque
volevano dirmi qualcosa d'importante
ogni mandavano un messaggio o mi
chiamavano qual è stato il risultato di
questa cosa che le persone non mi
chiamavano né mi mandava un messaggio
anche quando c'era qualcosa di
importante perché vedevano che ero il
raggiungibile ok quindi quando tutti
siamo abituati a vivere una certa realtà
con determinati servizi che diamo
proprio per scontato che qualcuno abbia
perché se qualcuno ti dal numero assisi
scrivimi poi ti scrive ato la cliente su
whatsapp diamo proprio scontato che ce
l'abbia ok ecco questa è una cosa molto
importante perché dal momento in cui tu
non ce l'hai e vi invito a farlo nel
caso anche solo per due giorni per
capire di cosa sto parlando
provate a dire qualcuno non a whatsapp
oppure non farvi trovare sullo sap è
impossibile c'è vivere è un casino
perché non hai sostanzialmente
comunicazione con nessuno tutti mi
venivano a dire sei diventato
irraggiungibile non ti si può più
parlare
non è vero però siete voi che siete
tutti abituati così ok ma detto questo
appunto ribadisco ci saranno anche
tantissimi modi di usufruire del
servizio per fare cose [ __ ] tipo
assisterà concerti anche da casa vostra
però nella maniera più [ __ ]
oppure non lo so veramente talmente
tanta roba che inutile che sta a farvi
l'elenco però gli spunti sono
incredibili
vedremo in che modo verrà realizzato
insomma fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate io
non lo so però in base anche a queste
premesse molto sterili fatemi sapere
insomma la vostra opinione qua sotto se
il mio è piaciuto come al solito il
documento è un mi piace iscritti al
canale e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video tanto anche nel
metaverso ci sarà mio telecomando
bellissima anche se negli anni sessanta
nome lo tira via nessuno quindi sticazzi
che fa rima con ragazzi
[Musica]